the vyasa family have come to buy sweets
for the hindi festival of diwali
this year the festival of lights holds
special significance
they lost their uncle to coronavirus at
the age of 67.
now even the festival they've been
looking forward to has been curtailed
what did you think this year is going to
be virtual we believe so we as a family
will meet
up on zoom or virtual meeting because of
the current lockdown
restrictions we are not be able to meet
and having get together or any parties
or exchange of sweets nothing like that
is going to happen and it's not just
families having to adapt
looking to enjoy their festivals in
lockdown normally temples welcome
hundreds of worshipers they're having to
improvise any way they can
the temple will go into thousands of
people's homes
delivering a spiritual message and
instilling
hope faith and confidence in people
through these difficult times and with
the hope that you know better times will
return
and the temple will reopen and we will
collectively celebrate festivals again
it's a sadness which doesn't just affect
hindus
the sikh religion also has a festival of
lights and it's called bundy shore
and at this time of year this goddard
would usually be full of worshippers
lockdown restrictions have put an end to
communal worship
the rules mean that people have to pray
alone
sonny tahili usually organizes
gatherings for thousands of people
but this year he's planning a virtual
event instead we're adapting our
on our platform that we created at this
beginning of the year at the start of
kovid so we'll be organizing
a large scale online event so sikhs
across the world can
basically tune in pray together and just
be together virtually
diwali is the victory of light over
darkness
certainly a message of positivity in
these challenging times
minricore sky news